bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de sept huit ans dit
et voici les titres
jean garrigues historien président du
comité d'histoire parlementaire et
politique nous livre son regard sur la
primaire et la prochaine élection
présidentielle
il était présent lors de l'événement
histoire de lire qui se déroulait ce
week end à versailles
la maison d'édition rue du monde à
voisins le bretonneux fête ses 20 ans
son fondateur alain serres nous explique
des secret de cette longévité rue du
monde participe cette année encore au
salon du livre de la jeunesse de
montreuil
et puis nous recevront en plateau stèle
peyrard elle aida créatrice une
collection de six livres adaptés pour
les enfants qui présentent des retards
de développement
nous allons laisser la parole à un
professeur d'histoire jean garrigues
nous l'avons rencontré à l'occasion d'un
événement histoire de lire qui se
déroulait à versailles et le week end
dernier et nous a livré son analyse de
la présidence et de l'élection
présidentielle à venir
l'incarnation de la fonction
présidentielle c'est la thématique de
votre dernier livre quelle différence
faites vous entre les présidents de la
vème république
oh la la c'est une très longue histoire
et c'est ce que j'essaie de raconter
dans ce bouquin sur les présidents au
coeur du pouvoir entre le général de
gaulle la majesté gaullienne qui parlait
d' éloignement voire de mystère et ce
qu'est devenue aujourd'hui la présidence
par une présidence de proximité une
présidence dit normal la différence est
évidemment considérable les rituels de
la présidence sont finalement restés les
mêmes le 14 juillet les conférences de
presse les voeux aux français mais en
revanche la manière d'exercer la
fonction présidentielle a totalement
changé
est-ce que s'étant bien est-ce que c'est
en mal c'est pas moi de le dire mais je
pense qu'elle a beaucoup changé
effectivement mais quel est le président
qui incarne le plus la fonction selon le
texte de la constitution
il est évident que le président qui
était le plus proche de sa constitution
que le général de gaulle il y en a
d'ailleurs fait évoluer l'interprétation
la pratique et même le texte puisque en
1962 il a fait voter une révision qui
donnait l'élection du président au
suffrage universel mais c'est vrai que
la caractéristique c'est que on est allé
notamment avec la loi du quinquennat en
l'an 2000 vers une sur
présidentialisation et le problème c'est
que cette sueur présidentialisation va
de pair avec la diminution des pouvoirs
réels des présidents de la république
qui sont contraints par les l'europe par
la mondialisation par la régionalisation
qui voient leur pouvoir réel diminué
mais qui en même temps ont un pouvoir au
sein des institutions qui est de plus en
plus important alors ça veut dire qu'il
faut être à la hauteur de ce pouvoir et
qu' il faut être à la hauteur de
l'incarnation
malheureusement la proximité la sur
médiatisation est le contraire de cette
hauteur et c'est tout le problème de la
vème république
quelle vision avez-vous de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 à l'élection de
2017 ne ressemble à aucune autre
d'abord parce que pour la première fois
il va y avoir deux primaires il y en a
une qui est en train de se dérouler à
droite une autre à gauche c'est quelque
chose de totalement inédit il y aura
peut-être un président de la république
en exercice qui va participer à une
primaire ce qui là encore est totalement
inédit et totalement contraire à
l'esprit des institutions de la vème
république
et puis il va y avoir un nombre de
candidats peut-être qu'on va battre le
record de 1900 de 2002 qui était de 15
candidats s'étaient déjà énorme
là on va avoir une multiplicité de
candidats on a aussi un facteur qui est
quand même très nouveau c'est que le
favori du premier tour est un candidat
de l'extrême droite en l'occurrence une
candidate marine le pen
bref toutes les cartes sont rebattues on
a quelque chose de
totalement nouveau et donc en principe
on va avoir un résultat qui va
surprendre beaucoup de monde
littérature jeunesse à présent il ya
tout juste 20 ans rue du monde été créé
à voisins le bretonneux la maison
d'édition est spécialisée dans les
ouvrages pour enfants elle sera présente
le 30 novembre au salon du livre de la
jeunesse à montreuil ou à montreuil
mélanie poker a rencontré alain serres
le créateur et directeur de la maison
d'édition 20 ans un gros chantier
beaucoup de travail
425 livres le réaliser depuis ce jour où
j'ai de 1996 où j'ai un peu follement
décidé de créer une maison d'édition
alors que j'étais auteur de livres
jeunesse j'avais publié une cinquantaine
de livres dans de nombreuses maisons
d'édition j'étais enseignant aussi à
saint quentin en yvelines à lui en cours
précisément et donc voilà l'idée de se
lancer follement pour construire un
espace éditorial un peu libre original
créatif qui prend les enfants au sérieux
voilà alors comme il n'y avait pas
d'argent pour le faire bah j'ai lancé
une sorte de crowdfunding avant l'heure
à la limite de la naissance d'internet à
la fin des années 90 on a pu faire les
tout premiers livres de rue du monde
dont son premier le grand livre des
droits de l'enfant qui quelque part
poser un petit peu le champ qui était
celui du riz du monde ne parlait des
enfants d'ici d'ailleurs le salon du
livre jeunesse de montreuil qui est le
grand rendez vous annuel du livre
jeunesse en france qui attire maintenant
d'ailleurs aussi des créateurs de toute
l'europe
c'est la principale manifestation en
europe
autour de la littérature jeunesse et aux
nous y participons depuis le premier
salon de 1996 où nous avons débarqué sur
un petit stand un mètre de large avec un
livre le grand livre des droits de
l'enfant illustré par tefe le petit
stand de l'époque a grandi aujourd'hui
nous avons un grand stand généreux
ouvert qui accueille beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'auteurs illustrateurs qui
viennent si c'est un grand moment de
discussion des changes
voilà l puis cette année comme c'est les
20 ans de rue du monde on va faire des
petits cadres rouges en avait de beaux
posters et on va se faire plaisir aussi
les médias à part terrifie bien sûr les
médias par le très vieux du livre
jeunesse un très très peu je crois qu'il
n'a pas perçu en france qu'il y avait un
livre jeunesse extrêmement brillant qui
fait justement briller les yeux du monde
entier
tous les professionnels du livre et de
l'enfance il se crée ici des livres
extraordinaires beaucoup douze mille
nouveaux titres par an nous on n'en fait
qu'une trentaine là dedans mais il ya un
très beau livre jeunesse
en france on en parle trop peu c'est
vraiment dommage ça fait pourtant partie
jeux pan de cette exception culturelle
française
et là c'est vraiment l'occasion de
rencontrer le public qui
et qui portent notre travail je dirais
il ya aujourd'hui des aficionados du
livre jeunesse beaucoup d'adultes de
jeunes adultes s'offre des livres pour
enfants entre adultes aussi parce que
c'est un art très vivant qui parle du
monde d'aujourd'hui aux enfants et ce
soir nous recevons estelle peyrard dans
soirs comme ça vous êtes la créatrice
d'une collection de six livres adaptés
pour les enfants qui ont des retards de
développement
alors ma première question pourquoi
avoir décidé de faire ses boucles à ça
mon histoire personnelle qui m'a amené à
ça puisque j'ai un enfant car retard
développement et en particulier un
retard de langage et quand on a été
confronté à ces retards on a rapidement
cherché ce qu'on pouvait faire nous en
tant que parents et on n'a pas trouvé de
manière immédiate
donc je recherchais beaucoup de choses
et j'ai fini par créer des supports pour
mon fils' et ses supports tous les
dommages finalement que d'autres
familles aient pas accès
donc j'ai travaillé avec des
orthophonistes pour savoir si ce que
j'avais créé c'est ça pourrait être
pertinent pour d'autres enfants qui ont
des difficultés à dire leurs premiers
mots et voilà donc la première
collection des éditions les tortues net
l'interdire talent titre - qu'est-ce
qu'on trouve dans ces petits bouquins
alors dans ses bouquins c'est on trouve
essentiellement des images cd imagier
donc un imagier c'est une image un mot
leur spécificité c'est d'être adapté
pour les enfants qui ont des difficultés
de prononciation donc dans ses livres
ses il y a des mots faciles à prononcer
il ya aussi des comptines simplifier
pour être plus facile à prononcer le but
c'est de mettre les enfants en situation
de réussite plus qu'avec des supports
classiques qu'on peut trouver en
librairie
c'est vraiment innovant ses bouquets y
en a pas beaucoup
c'est vous cale à ce type là de bouquins
il y en a pas du tout ça n'existait pas
c'est pour ça que je les ai créé
après innovant c'est peut-être un grand
mot parce que le principe est assez
simple
ici il s'agit simplement de mettre des
mots qui sont plus accessibles d'un
point de vue prononciation pour l'enfant
que les difficultés de ceux sur cet
aspect là alors il ya vraiment des
effets après que les enfants utilisent
ces livres alors ouais c'est pas
scientifique ni magique mais les effets
j'étais au moins constater sur mon fils
c'est puis ils ont été validées par des
orthophonistes et en fait ce que j'ai
constaté avec mon fils c'est qu'il y
avait quand même un petit effet magique
au démarrage parce que le livre est en
fait pour lui et lui étant plus
accessible
voilà il avait tout de suite un peu la
fierté de pouvoir assez rapidement
développé une certaine maîtrise de
quelques mots qu'il avait paravent et
vous avez travaillé pendant combien de
temps avec ses orthophoniste pour créer
ses livres alors le projet il a démarré
il ya un petit peu plus d'un an
au départ c'était surtout un blogue pour
échanger de l'information avec des
parents sur le retard de développement
puis ça a donné des ateliers avec les
parents pour les aider à faire face à un
retard de développement aux retards de
langage et enfin ces livres qui sont
arrivés cet été vous avez vu qu'il y
avait beaucoup de parents qui en avaient
besoin de ces livres est ce qu'ils sont
sont seuls face à ces problèmes là oui
alors on sen seul c'est sur le retard de
langage c'est quand même environ 7 à 8 %
des enfants qui entre en maternelle
donc ça fait ça fait quand même un bon
nombre alors dans retard de langage ya
de tout
et des enfants qui ont des petites
difficultés à construire des phrases et
puis il ya les enfants qui ont même des
difficultés à lire
ne serait ce qu'un seul mot donc
l'éventail assez large mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que en tant que parent on peut
avoir ce sentiment de se sentir un petit
peu inutile face à ça parce qu'il ya une
très bonne prise en charge médicale
orthophonique etc en france mais par
contre en tant que parent n'a pas
forcément un rôle assigné et dans ses
livres en plus d'être adapté aux enfants
on donne d'un tas de conseils aux
parents sur la manière d'aborder le
retard de langage de leurs enfants
alors quelles sont ses conseils moi je
crois que le premier conseil c'est de ne
pas braquer leurs fins donc de ne pas le
le fort c est à dire à répéter mais
d'être vraiment dans le jeu quand quand
on lit par exemple un imagier ou ou
quand on travaille avec lui le langage
même si travailler c'est pas le bon
terme
mais quand on est sur ces aspects là
avec son propre enfant faut pas qu'on
soit dans l'exercice faut qu'on soit
vraiment dans le jeu pour garder son
rôle de parent et pour pas le braquer
parce qu'en général un retard de langage
ont pu se détecte vers deux trois quatre
ans une bonne période où les enfants
sont dans le nom ils peuvent avoir un
retard de langage et très alors sur la
période dit non donc voilà il s'agit de
de garder un esprit ludique par rapport
à tout ça c'est pas facile parce qu'on a
un petit peu l'angoissé enfants parlent
pas compréhensible des parents alors
c'est quoi les retours les retours sont
assez positifs les parents qui sont
concernés j'ai pas besoin de leur
expliquer à quoi ça sert parce que il
voit tout de suite l'avantagé de ces
images -notamment par sonorités qui font
travailler un son après l'autre ils sont
assez enthousiaste donc voilà j'espère
que j'aurai assez de parents
enthousiastes pour pouvoir continuer à
développer des collections comme ça et
dites moi alors c'est quoi la suite
alors la suite s'est trouvé des
librairies qui diffuse mes livres et
puis comme je le disais continuer à
développer des collections livre on
envisage aussi une application tablettes
ouais on a des ateliers qui sont déjà en
place et on envisage de de l'est bien
sûr les poursuivre et puis
éventuellement d'adapter légèrement le
format pour l'an prochain
et bien je vous remercie madame paiera
merci à vous c'est la fin de ce sept
huit invités merci de nous avoir suivis
et puis surtout bonne soirée à tous